violences scolaires un plan de toute
urgence pour l'un des départements les
plus touchés en france la seine saint
denis
le garde du corps de diana trevor reid
jaune se retrouve peu à peu la mémoire
et puis à londres aujourd'hui le
testament de la princesse de galles a
été rendu public
les boulangers veulent être maîtres chez
eux les artisans conteste l'abrogation
du règlement interdisant fabricant de
pain industriel de porter le nom de
boulanger corse les élections cantonales
pourrait constituer un premier pas de
retour à la légalité républicaine
apparemment c'est mal parti en quête ce
soir dans ce journal
la coupe du monde de football c'est dans
100 jours tout juste la machine
publicitaire se met en marche les
demandes de locations d'appartements
affluent mais attention aux arnaques à
touristes
voilà monsieur bonsoir la violence à
l'école un problème qui se pose
désormais à l'échelon national dans
notre pays avec des départements où la
cote d' alerte a été dépassé depuis bien
longtemps
c'est le cas de la seine saint denis en
ile de france un rapport officiel remis
au ministre de l'éducation nationale la
semaine dernière nos têtes en guise de
conclusion que dans ce département
tout est plus difficile que nulle part
ailleurs
sans attendre le gouvernement a donc
décidé d'agir en adoptant un plan
d'urgence je dirais de toute urgence
thibault de barbeyrac face à face le
proviseur d'un lycée des beaux quartiers
de paris et des enseignants de seine
saint denis une opération symbolique des
prof de banlieue qui voulait faire
connaître leurs difficiles conditions de
travail
la seine-saint-denis un département
sinistré où l'échec scolaire atteint des
sommets un département pour lequel
ségolène royal et claude allègre annonce
des mesures exceptionnelles qui
prendront effet dès septembre prochain
ce sont d'abord une dizaine de collèges
supplémentaires qui vont être classés en
zone d'éducation prioritaire dans ces
établissements
le nombre d'heures d'enseignement va
augmenter considérablement plus de
courant ce qui est plus d'encadrement
les ministres multiplient par deux le
nombre d'emplois jeunes et créé des
postes de personnels de santé
chaque établissement classé en zep aura
sa propre infirmière à plus long terme
la scolarisation dès l'âge de 2 ans
moyen de lui très efficace face à
l'échec scolaire
va être favorisé le nombre d'élèves par
établissement et par classe devrait
diminuer
enfin les ministres réfléchissent à des
mesures qui inciteront les enseignants
et les personnels d'encadrement à venir
travailler en seine-saint-denis et y
rester en fait ce que voudrait le
ministre de l'éducation nationale c'est
que l'ensemble des établissements
scolaires de ce département et au delà
dans toutes les zones prioritaires
puissent fonctionner sur le modèle du
collège colonel fabien à montreuil sur
scène cité en exemple positif tous les
problèmes de violence n'ont pas été
résolus mais vous allez le voir des
décisions concrètes ont été prises
et ça fonctionne nathalie moisan eric de
l'agneau reportage
qu'est ce que je vois sur la tête et qui
va disparaître dès le seuil du collège
le matin à 8 heures une présence qui
rappelle le règlement intérieur
symboliquement est important que les
gosses sache que le principal est là
pour les accueillir le matin et que
lorsque je grapho je n'ai pas fait
mentir le matin les enfants l'on chante
dit je savais que dans la maison et
avait l'obligation car chaque détail
compte
la peinture répandue sur les interphones
pendant les vacances sera lavé dans
l'heure pour éviter que les dégradations
ne s'installe une présence adulte ont
renforcé par deux appelés du contingent
et deux emplois jeunes
les dégâts des aides éducateurs avec une
mission précise alors pour lui mme
forest liné que les 900 mais sinon il ya
quand même trois autres sens avec deux
scènes de co paris et puis l'excusé hugo
sada simon une absence une heure de
colle lorsque l'absentéisme perdure la
famille est prévenu puis la caisse
d'allocations familiales qui a la
possibilité d' interrompre le versement
des aides aux parents corinne est bien
le lien entre l'école et la rue entre
l'éducation nationale et les services
sociaux je crois que ça répond à un
besoin des des partenaires extérieurs
qui téléphonent pour savoir comment se
passe la relation avec les enfants au
sein du collège et que le collège a
envie de savoir comment ça se passe à
l'extérieur
mais la vraie nouveauté ici c'est le
partenariat école police justice tous
les faits de violence sont immédiatement
signalée par fax au parquet et à la
direction de la police urbaine où le
collège c'est le seul endroit dans
lequel on va pouvoir leur apprendre la
vie en société parce que c'est le seul
endroit qu'ils vont fréquenter dans
lequel in-game des normes ce qui veut
dire que nous avons par rapport à ce
public un devoir d'exigence un devoir
d'exigence qui passe par un changement
des mentalités
certains enseignants hésitent encore à
signaler les actes de violence qui
lisent comme des échecs personnels ya
six mois un peu plus de six mois
maintenant que la princesse diana et son
compagnon dodi al fayed sont mortes dans
un accident de voiture à paris en
angleterre la sphère n'a jamais vraiment
quitté la une des grands quotidiens
populaires aujourd'hui c'est l'un
d'entre eux le mirror qui publie un
entretien du garde du corps de la
princesse le seul survivant qui peu à
peu dit il retrouve la mémoire des faits
valérie remet
à la une du quotidien anglais the mirror
trêve et rhys jones et cette drôle de
précisions je n'ai pas été payé pour
parler l'ancien garde du corps des dodge
al-fayed
aujourd'hui employé par son père
mohammad al fayed dit avoir quelques
souvenirs concernant la soirée du 30
août et notamment celui d'avoir été
suivie depuis l'arrière du ritz par une
moto et deux voitures dont une blanche
toujours rien en revanche sur l'accident
lui-même mais le souvenir d'avoir
entendu diana appelé d'audi juste après
le crash
les éléments qui la porte pour l'instant
rien de neuf à lenquête travers lui
jones parle également d'henri paul qui
conduisait la mercedes ce soir là le
garde du corps dit n'avoir appris que
plus tard que les deux boissons cabu
henri-paul devant lui était en fait du
pastis dans l' enquête
si la plupart des employés du rite
décrivant ripoll comme un professionnel
irréprochable de barmen parlent eux de
son penchant pour la boisson
le soir de l'accident dit l'un d'entre
eux henri-paul titubait en sortant du
bar mais de cela très vite jones n'a
apparemment aucun souvenir et assure
n'avoir rien remarqué d'anormal dans le
comportement du numéro deux de la
sécurité du rex le père de dodi al fayed
mohamed al fayed homme d'affaires
richissime manteau n'entend pas en
rester là il veut prouver qu'il ya bien
eu un complot contre son fils d'un autre
côté mohamed al fayed n'est pas en odeur
de sainteté à londres où il vient d'être
arrêtés puis relâchés sous caution dans
une affaire de vol de documents et de
bijoux enfin aujourd'hui a été rendue
publique le testament de la princesse de
galles qui lègue sa fortune à ses deux
enfants
une fois déduite bien entendu la part
qui revient à l'état
londres etienne et nantes le jour de
gloire de christine lanne stone elle a
été la première a acheté pour 7 francs
50 ce matin la copie du testament de la
princesse de galles
bien sûr que je vais le lire mais c'est
surtout un document historique
les dernières volontés de la maman des
deux princes on apprend de ce document
mais est ce une surprise que diana était
l'une des 1000 premières fortunes du
royaume à environ 215 millions de francs
dont 85 sont déjà partis en droits de
succession dans les caisses de l'état
ses deux enfants se partageront la
presque totalité du reste dont ils
pourront bénéficier à l'âge de 25 ans
ce testament dont la copie est annoncé
comme l'un des best seller de l'année
prévoit encore que les centaines de
millions de francs générée par la vente
des tasses des assiettes des cuillères
et les t-shirts seront partagés entre
les princes et les oeuvres de charité
clin d'oeil romantique de l'histoire à
la demande de la famille de diana le
seul objet qui ne sera offert à personne
en particulier pour être réservé à son
peuple tout entier c'est sa robe de
mariée
en france les artisans boulangers en
colère le règlement qui interdisait aux
fabricants et revendeurs de pain
industriel de prétendre au titre de
boulanger a été abrogée aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs dizaine de préfectures en
france les artisans boulangers ont donc
déposé un texte de protestation
demandant à ce que leur spécificité soit
de nouveau reconnu reportage stéphane
guez lianke ce coup de leyme jacky on
est fiers comme d'une signature artisans
du pain depuis 1963
il est tous les jours aux fourneaux dès
1h du matin son seul titre celui de
boulanger plus qu'une profession pour
lui une passion la levure et c'est après
c'est à moi de d'avoir un pain qu'ils
soient développés qui est du goût clé ça
c'est ça c'est ça mon métier ça
industriel il s'occupe pas de ces
choses-là à lui pour lui c'est l'heure
la rentabilité et
mais contraint avoir une certaine
fabrication aux quantités de fabrication
autre lieu autre méthode
derrière la façade traditionnels se
cache en fait un terminal de cuisson
tous les matins la pâte produite en
usine et livrées
ici elle est seulement cuites les
artisans refuse d'entendre appelé
boulanger c'est sa brique en eux par
l'industriel le pas du stress ça
n'existe pas sait on jamais sur une
logistique et derrière je sais les mêmes
pétrole c'est les mêmes jeux ouvriers je
dirais que les farines parfois élaboré
c'est le même goût selon wang on chez
renault on saurait donc histoire de goût
car derrière le nouveau boulanger se
livre en fait une bataille pour la
qualité un fonds industriel pourra-t-il
être aussi bon que celui pétri à la main
la réponse nous l'avons demandé à notre
gastronomes maison évidemment la grande
différence c'est que dans l'industrie on
n'a pas le temps de laisser fermenter le
bateau un la pâte à pain elle va cuire
peut-être la même façon ce rappel est
très bonne farine mais le temps que
prend l'artisan pour laisser fermenter
c'est tout le temps de la rom du pain et
ça on ne tombe pas dans l'industrie dit
même penser qu'un vrai
hall et surtout ce que les industriels
n'auront jamais c'est le chant du pain
frais à la sortie du four c'est ce soir
l'un des moments les plus attendus au
salon de l'agriculture à paris qui a
ouvert ses portes hier le début du
concours général des animaux d'élevage
qui consacre les plus belles bêtes de
l'année cette présentation n'est pas
seulement un grand moment disons
folklorique c'est aussi tout autour un
véritable marché avec des enjeux
économiques très importants et dans ce
domaine la france est très bien placé
reportage ans yves perrin à philippe
turpault le prix d'une vedette
bien sûr il vaut mieux avoir l'oeil du
spécialiste pour en apprécier l'effort
et au salon évidemment les spécialistes
sont légion pour cette première vente
aux enchères de la race limousine
les prix n'ont guère flambé 85 mille
francs pour joe bar han sont éleveurs en
espérer tu te sens enfin cette vente a
fait quelques acheteurs euros
j'ai acheté d'enchaîner que vont qui
difficile à acquérir
j'ai marché normal c'est très cher c'est
l'occasion d'avoir acquérir un bel
animal c'est quand même pas donné à tout
le monde quand même de pouvoir mais
france mais le froid dans un animal ils
ont que le prix normal oscille entre 15
et les mines plus de dix mille francs
pour le d'acheteurs étrangers 6 mai un
éleveur italiens
trente mille francs pour cette belle
vache c'est difficile de juger si c'est
cher mais il faut savoir prendre des
risques
en fait la race la plus vendue à
l'étranger c'est la holstein la société
génétique france exporte 30 mille vaches
vivante par an et un million de
paillettes issus des meilleurs taureaux
de l'élevage français ses clients les
éleveurs du monde entier
la nouvelle europe qu'on appelle
toujours le moyen-orient avec le liban
le qatar les émirats et puis le mal le
maghreb qui continuent à toujours venir
acheter malgré tourne à la crise de la
vache folle qui nous fait mal c'est
toujours difficile de pouvoir ré ouvrir
des frontières qui se ferme pour des
problèmes politiques des problèmes
sanitaires qui n'en sont pas alors la
société reçoit beaucoup même si ce n'est
pas où selon consignes les contrats ne
sont pas les moments déjà rachat c'est
pourquoi renforcer les liens et bon
discuter les programmes des gens
prochain et à l'abri comme quoi le salon
baby culture n'est pas seulement la plus
grande ferme de france
le nouveau préfet de corse bernard
bonnet victime peut être d'une très
mauvaise plaisanterie on a vite décès a
été publié en langue catalane dans le
journal l'indépendant de perpignan qui a
présenté aujourd'hui ses excuses nouveau
préfet de corse qui a rencontré ce matin
le premier ministre lionel jospin pour
faire le point avec lui sur la situation
dans l'île notamment l' enquête sur
l'assassinât du préfet erignac qui pour
l'instant officiellement du moins ne
donne rien
dans tous les domaines la volonté
affichée du gouvernement de ramener la
corse dans la légalité républicaine va
se heurter à de sérieuses difficultés
exemple les prochaines élections
cantonales fin mars à bastia surprise
d'un candidat qui a vu le nombre de
votants augmentait de près de 40% dans
son canton
à la veille du scrutin benoît duquesne
ni une faute il y à des colères
prévisible celle de jacques pasquier ont
fait partie conseiller général sortant
rpr du 3e canton de bastia il n'a pas
apprécié de voir le nombre des inscrits
dans son canton augmenter brutalement de
près de 40%
à l'en croire c'est un mauvais coups de
son adversaire de gauche proche de la
mairie
alors ils dénoncent 120 de ses 400
nouveaux inscrits devant la justice mais
dénoncer n'est pas prouvée et jacques
parce qu'unique est débouté
j'y suis a plus rien
aux 120 construit si je devrais me
firent 120 perd 120 me suis dit que ces
gens n'hésitent pas à s'impliquer et le
juge les mannequins sur les listes
électorales c'est le comble monsieur on
est ridicules en compte mais j'irai
quand même aux élections je n'ai pas
perdu croyez moi ne voyait que la fraude
aux yeux parce que j'ai beaucoup donné
et ria j'ai des amis julien dominici
représente le maire à la commission
électorale de bastia ce matin là la
décision de justice rendue les membres
des bureaux viennent signer lévis défini
on est plus de 100 recours entre cd
pressés et c'est jacky et sur les
centres où ils m'ont juste une vingtaine
de sûrement pourquoi combat et tous les
autres ont été inscrits et une 5,5 à peu
près de jacky qui ont été rejetées ça
prouve qu'on est clair favorite et ses
montées mais sur ce point que j'en ai
besoin de prouver comme les mains parce
que devant le tribunal jacky passe lui
ni lui ne décolère pas
parce que la foule mais je suis sage
endroit que je vous le dise la faute à
joindre quoi la foule dans un endroit
gland soucieux mais en mairie 7e colère
un support ce n'est pas la première fois
que le bureau électoral est mise en
cause et l'on ne voit pas pourquoi des
candidats ne pourrait pas en toute
légalité rameuté leurs supporters pour
qu'ils s'inscrivent sur les listes
je dirais comme des segments mon défunt
père qui était un élu avant moi je
m'adresse à ceux là encore sans leur
design bisous leader big mon pognon et
vieux faudrait pas renier maintenant par
avec les élections à mon poste ou en
fraudant ou en faisant de faut marcher
mes parents ma vie à la sueur de leur
front
mais ce canton de bastien a tellement
surpris que le préfet lui aussi a
introduit des recours pour 50 d'entre
eux la mairie a corrigé sa copie pour
les autres il a été débouté
alors campagne électorale oblige edmond
simeoni est reparti en guerre il porte
plainte pour fraude personnes la justice
pénale a les moyens pense-t-il de
débusquer les inscriptions de
complaisance
leshop ch a décidé d'assainir il ya
quelques années les matrices électorale
a supprimé 40 mille électeurs
et tout doucement année après année le
système politique traditionnelle avec la
complicité appelons à la différence de
la justice des commissions
administratives à reconstituer le
matelas des lecteurs book en prévision
de la fraude car bastia n'est pas la
seule visée d'autres listes ailleurs ont
augmenté elles aussi plus vite que la
population une inflation qu'un sursaut
de civisme d'intérêt pour la campagne ne
suffit pas à expliquer on parle
d'escadron volant de nomadisme
électorale en fonction de ses amitiés ou
de ses intérêts des pratiques anciennes
et contestable mais qui ne sont même pas
toujours condamnable
puis encore à quinze jours des élections
régionales cette fois ci du dff et le
rpr ont présenté aujourd'hui une
plateforme électorale commune qui sera
la base de la campagne des candidats
dans les 87 départements sur les 95 au
total 87 départements où il y est fait
happer air font liste commune
le procès de maurice papon à bordeaux
après les témoignages des résistants la
semaine dernière cette semaine la cour
s'intéresse à la période de l'épuration
tout de suite donc après la libération d
le mois d'août 44 comment s'est opérée
le tri parmi les hauts fonctionnaires de
la préfectorale
entre ceux qui ont été condamnés qui
sont restés en place ou qui ont même
connu une promotion comme ce fut le cas
pour maurice papon dominique verdeilhan
patrick deschênes cas image trompeuse
parties civiles et défense n'ont pas
subitement la même lecture du dossier
le seul objet de cet étonnant
rapprochement et l'ordre des plaidoiries
côté parties civiles on note que si pape
on est épargné lors de l'épuration cela
ne peut-être une erreur
côté défense on s'appuie sur les témoins
de l'époque jean morin a supervisé
l'épuration de la préfectorale en 44 sur
200 fonctionnaires 60 ont été révoqués
quinze l'essai en place à aucun pape
édiles des moins il n'a été reproché la
déportation des juifs
maurice papon ici aux côtés du général
en septembre 44 à bordeaux a été promu
préfet est resté en poste à bordeaux le
préfet pierre somveille était lui aussi
à bordeaux au moment de l'épuration
je n'ai rien entendu contre papon dit il
est pourtant la délation allaient bon
train
maurice papon aurait aimé que son procès
s'achève sur cette note favorable
c'était oublier les témoins de la
dernière heure
à commencer par le procureur de cologne
le 16 février
des menaces de mort l'avait empêché
témoigner il sera entendu mercredi
furieux maurice papon se lève et
proteste violemment contre l'audition
d'un allemand qui je cite appartient à
une nation qui a les responsabilités que
l'on sait et qui se mêlent aujourd'hui
d'un procès français dans la salle les
victimes s'insurge et un de leurs
avocats note qu'il aurait été préférable
que cette hostilité vis-à-vis des
allemands s'exprime dès 1942 en marge de
ce procès le conseil de l'ordre des
avocats vient d'engager des poursuites
disciplinaires contre serge et arno
klarsfeld pour avoir mis en cause
l'impartialité du président de la cour
d'assises
jean-luc castagnède en révélant un lien
de parenté avec certaines parties
civiles
l'actualité internationale maintenant
quatre ans après le génocide perpétré au
rwanda la situation est à ce point
dégradée de nouveau dans le pays que le
gouvernement à majorité tutsi cette fois
ci a décidé d'employer les grands moyens
pour mettre un terme aux incursions de
miliciens hutus réfugiés notamment à la
frontière de l'ex zaïre et qui ont
entrepris des incursions régulières
dans les villages où une sèment la
terreur et la mort c'est un nouveau
conflit ethnique qui s'est engagé dans
une indifférence dix ans presque
générale reportages et rythme de part et
d'autre de la route plus au nord tous
ont été coupées trou propice aux
embuscades depuis près d'un an tout le
nord-ouest du rwanda est de nouveau en
guerre civile
d'un côté l'armée patriotique rwandaise
à majorité tutsi de l'autre la dans les
collines invisible d'anciens soldats et
des miliciens ils sont où tout et rêvent
de reprendre le pouvoir perdu en 1994 ou
pire ne poursuivre le génocide qui a
fait au moins 800 mille morts dans ce
pays des rebelles que le retour massif
des réfugiés hutu de l'ex zaïre il ya un
an a considérablement renforcé dans les
villages les infiltrés c'est la
terminologie officielle retrouvent leurs
familles et en même temps un soutien
logistique indispensable à la guérilla
ce village qui hnidy a été attaqué trois
jours plus tôt sans doute jugé trop
favorable au pouvoir sans attaquer par
télex mais quand même nom mais elle
voyants ont riposté et vous êtes brûler
la commune pour que puisse montrer
qu'ils sont forts vous croyez qu'il
bénéficie de complicités dans la
population ici autour il ya quand même
lesquels et les complices y en a qui
passent ne peuvent pas attaquer comme sa
femme complice par exemple c'est la
discipline ac thiago qui était mort
c'est quelqu'un qui a travaillé ces
dernières est passé chaque fois la
commune de morts chez les assaillants
neuf parmi les villageois la taxe n'a
duré que dix sept minutes
trop peu pour libérer les 52 prisonniers
de son cachot commune les prisons les
objectifs pour les rebelles
les détenus libérés viennent souvent
grossir leurs rangs il semble bien que
l'armée ne perdra pas le contrôle de la
zone
mais elle paraît incapable d'en juguler
l'insécurité
le gouvernement rwandais le sait preuves
qui ne trompent pas c'est le chef d'état
major en personne qui dirige les
opérations sur le terrain aux
accusations qui font de son armée une
machine de répression sanglante il
répond sans détour quand je parle de
neutralisation en fait mon objectif est
de les frapper sur le champ de bataille
et de les tuer qui pas de les arrêter
quand je suis en opération je n'y vais
pas pour des arrestations
je dis à mes soldats vous devez
parfaitement visez vous devez tirer pour
tuer soutenir notre pas pour arrêter je
ne fais pas un travail de police ici je
suis en opération mais en même temps
nous avons les prisonniers
ces prisonniers les voici exhibées par
l'armée rwandaise des repentis
volontaire ou forcée impossible à savoir
le pouvoir rwandais dit les rééduquer
pour en faire des informateurs il espère
ainsi reprendre durablement l'avantagent
dans une région traditionnellement
hostile aux tutsis une région abandonnée
par les observateurs étrangers trop
dangereuse
une région où le drame rwandais se
poursuit son témoin
reportage eric meunier roger motte
manifestations réprimées dans la
violence dans la province serbe du
kosovo dans cette région la majorité de
la population est albanaise et n'accepte
pas le pouvoir serbe
les émeutes qui ont fait au total 20
morts 16 albanais quatre policiers
serbes
rappelons que le kosovo a perdu son
statut autonome et que des mouvements
pour l'indépendance si on est dans cette
province dirigée par belgrade
depuis hier soir le chancelier helmut
kohl qui doit se représenter dans six
mois environ pour un nouveau mandat
après seize années passées à la tête de
l'allemagne connaît son adversaire
gerhard schröder officiellement investi
par le parti social démocrate
après son triomphe électoral hier soir
dans son land de basse saxe à 53 ans
gare à trader passe volontiers pour un
charmeur auprès des électeurs et auprès
des dames berlin olivier werner le
schroder des années 68 ne ressemble en
rien aux chaudes airs des années de vie
l'ancien gauchiste purs et durs
affectionne aujourd'hui des gros cigares
les cravates italienne et les jolies
femmes c'est sa quatrième épouse qu'il
embrasse ici mais plus que tout c'est le
pouvoir qui est nul ce provincial de 53
ans
parti de rien c'est un homme qui sait
prendre les décisions et qui fait en
sorte que ses décisions à louer sont
aussi suivis par des fêtes dominer une
machine politique au sein de sa
formation le parti social démocrate tout
le monde avait des yeux de chimène
aujourd'hui pour lui sa candidature à la
chancellerie plus personne ne la
conteste que c'est comme si votre vie
resserre des nids-de-poule aux élections
de septembre avait déjà gagné la
première manche
notre succès c'est le résultat d'une
politique orientée vers les intérêts des
travailleurs
gerhard schröder a déjà levé le voile
sur ses priorités l'emploi la croissance
l'innovation la sécurité et la formation
d'un triangle germaneau anglo-français
le jeune loup qui prenait des notes
derrière ou lybrand il ya plus de 20 ans
et presse à prendre le pouvoir
la dynamique électorale va jouer
incontestablement en faveur de gerhard
schröder ces prochaines semaines
mais le chancelier kohl n'a sans doute
pas dit son dernier mot malgré la claque
qui n'a reçu dans l'état de l'iowa la
mère de famille qui souvenez-vous avait
mis au monde cet enfant dont on
craignait un moment que certains ne
puissent survivre et finalement rentrer
chez elle avec tous les bambins et tout
le quartier se relaient pour l'aider à
pouponner washington maryse burgot il
est aujourd'hui l'un d'eux papa les
coûts célèbre au monde mais il ne veut
pas que c'est cette bd soit transformé
en plus si ce que vous dites est vivante
caché sous les deux couvertures il ya
donc 9 à lille 3 kg 4 et alexis 2 kg 5
les deux derniers 17 supplée de l'iowa a
quitté l'hôpital
les cinq autres bébés de la famille plus
résistants à leur naissance était rentré
à la maison depuis plusieurs semaines
mais ils sont venus avec leurs parents
chercher les deux petits derniers nous
les avons tous emmenés ici avec nous
pour avoir une sorte de réunion de
famille et nous allons tous rentrés
ensemble à la maison c'est ça être une
famille et qui le pape a le sourire la
maman elle laisse échapper quelques
larmes
maintenant ça va faire bizarre d'un coup
venir ici tous les jours pourquoi
pleurer vous pourquoi quand il veut que
je fleurs quatre petits garçons et trois
petits sets et b cette maman la imagine
peut-être ce qui l'attend à la maison un
dernier au revoir au personnel de
l'hôpital et la voiture offerte par la
petite ville de carlyle prend la route
avec sa précieuse famille à la maison
soixante volontaires vont se relayer
pour aider monsieur et madame cog est un
couple modeste mais très religieux pour
qui ces sept bébés sont un don de dieu
le gouverneur de l'état de l'iowa a
promis qu une maison plus grande leur
serait offerte en attendant les dons
affluent et ils sont les bienvenus
pour assurer l'éducation de leurs
enfants les maths qu'aux guerres ont
besoin d'un million de dollars et si
vous avez envie de voir le visage de ses
célèbres bébé il nous faut vous montrer
ces images d'archivés c'était il ya deux
mois
depuis les septuples et ont été
soigneusement protégé de la presse
la coupe du monde de football nous
sommes à j - sens très exactement les
choses commencent donc vraiment à
prendre tournure
aujourd'hui le président de la
république jacques chirac a reçu 100
jeunes venant des dix villes où auront
lieu les différentes rencontres
parallèlement les campagnes
publicitaires commencent à fleurir sur
les panneaux des grandes villes les
conseils autorise font l'objet d'un
livre de recommandations pour éviter
tout anna arnaque de la part de certains
commerçants indélicats y en a toujours
enfin les parisiens qui veulent louer
des appartements à des supporters
étrangers n'ont que l'embarras du choix
reportage florent gautreau jean paul
liot temps on attendait zidane djorkaeff
et on a eu madame michu une concierge ou
souriante qui rappelle gentiment au
parisien que dans son jour
c'est le grand jour l'idylle la
concierge c'est lui qui l'a eu le
publicitaire hervé brossard a voulu
montrer que la coupe du monde ce n'était
pas que du foot avec un message clair
pour les parisiens pendant le mondial
fait la fête par la tête
c'est la france kindaichi accueille
celle qui reçoit et ce ne sont pas onze
joueurs qui reçoivent ces milliers ces
milliers de gens se sont tous les
français donc effectivement c'est un
match pour la france et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous pensons que c'est à
tout le monde de jouer et pas uniquement
joueurs après la concierge le héros sera
un chauffeur de taxi jovial autant
accueillir le monde entier avec un grand
sourire
ils ont une mauvaise réputation
vis-à-vis des étrangers
je crois qu'à cette occasion c'est le
moment ou jamais de se rattraper avec
350 mille touristes attendus en juin la
france va changer de visage certains
propriétaires l'ont compris ils ont
décidé de louer leur appartement pendant
la durée de la coupe avec à la clé une
bonne affaire financière le montant des
loyers va exploser au mois on peut dire
que
on peut dire que 50% de plus ça existe
et c'est acceptable cela aussi le
confort des appartements et à la semaine
c'est à peu près à peu près l'équivalent
50 % de plus
et quand on a une terrasse de 300 mètres
carrés face à la tour eiffel l'effet
coupe du monde est évident pendant un
mois la terrasse du restaurant le totem
sera utilisé comme studio par deux
chaînes de télévision une allemande et
une mexicaine
ça vous rapporte qu'en chiffres plus que
d'habitude 20 à 30% on va dire et
concrètement combien ça coûte une soirée
ici pour un exemple la télévision
mexicaine pour une soirée de 150
personnes à partir de 100 mille francs
un événement exceptionnel vacances
exceptionnelles le séjour durera sept
jours en moyenne le temps de voir au
moins deux matches depuis le tirage au
sort les hôtels se remplissent trois
cent mille nuits sont réservés et les
brésiliens qui reste en force compte
bien rester plus d'une semaine ces
supporters qui viennent d'amérique du
sud viennent souvent pour deux pour de
longs séjours de longue durée de
plusieurs dizaines de jours voire 33
jours pour les brésiliens qui sont
certains que leur que leur pays sera
qualifié pour la finale à trois mois et
demi du jour j tout le monde l'a compris
le mondial est un enjeu national
dix jeunes représentants des 10 sites de
la coupe sont venus présenter à l'elysée
des projets d'animation
bref tout le monde est prêt cette coupe
du monde
il ne reste plus qu'à la gagner la bible
des gastronomes mais est sorti
aujourd'hui le michelin 98 il y a trente
et un promu à une étoile 47 l'ont perdu
cette année il y a peu de sanctions mais
pas du tout de sanctions même pour les
trois états et trois étoiles la plus
haute note un exploit tout de même alain
ducasse qui obtient trois étoiles pour
ses deux restaurants celui de paris
celui de monter cas et puis un grand
revenant pierre gagnaire en faillite à
saint-etienne il ya à peine deux ans il
renaît avec trois étoiles à paris
aujourd'hui patricia charnley bernard
puissance
attention gagne haut la baisse attention
le coup de feu en une heure pierre
gagnaire il sait très squeeze signés
doivent préparer une centaine de plats
le chef stimule ses troupes l'excellence
c'est d'abord une organisation diable
d'homme en 14 mois à paris gagnaire a
regagné les trois étoiles déjà obtenu
pour son restaurant de saint-etienne un
établissement qu'il avait dû fermer en
1996 pour des raisons financières
un échec alors douloureusement ressentir
gouffre financier la perte de tous ses
biens
tu voulu assumer ce que ce que j'avais
fait l'échec et je vais subit donc on va
le régler ça prendra du savon du temps
puis positiver et succession de
dynamique en dix ans pour ballack ligue
europa le verbe pas le cacher on va on
va l'utiliser on va enfin parce que ça
c'est pas perdu les deux mains avec ça
ça fonctionne bien
allez massa lors les vols gagner à 37
ans il est aux fourneaux depuis l'âge de
16 ans sa cuisine est d'abord inventive
lui ancien nouvelle avant tout
personnelle comme le disait son maître
de chapelle
pierre gagnaire pense que la cuisine
c'est beaucoup plus que des recettes
donc surprendre
d'où des associations de saveurs
subtiles comme du tourteau sur une jeune
et de bouillon de poule pierre gagnaire
est aussi passionné et qui sont grands
métiers
ça arrange indépendance où on peut
vraiment se réaliser
c'est un métier pas vraiment eu elle
sait manier de l'actuelle non plus mais
il ya quand même fou par deux une part
personnellement quels voisins disent on
avoue l'intelligence fonctionne vraiment
on a l'impression d'exister en tant
qu'homme
grâce à son épouse chantal à son équipe
et à des amis qui l'ont aidé
financièrement
pierre gagnaire a retrouvé le club des
21 restaurants à trois étoiles un beau
pied de nez aux déboires passés
c'est un des derniers grands
journalistes écrivains dans la lignée de
joseph kessel qui nous a quittés
aujourd'hui à l'âge de 84 ans lucien
bodard victime d'une crise cardiaque
il était né au fin fond de la chine d'un
père diplomate il fut le grand reporter
de la guerre d'indochine avant de
redevenir l'écrivain que l'on s'est
couronné par un prix goncourt il avait
comme l'expression le voeu une grande
gueule au service d'un très grand talent
georges est indissociable bodart et sa
machine à écrire sa naissance en chine
en 1914 le marquera profondément
c'était au temps où les seigneurs de la
guerre régner par la terreur
très jeune il s'affranchit de tous
fréquentent les bordels et les palais de
la chine impériale devenue journaliste
pour france soir il est de ces grands
reporters de légende
halak est celle à la cendre ars dès 1946
il parcourt l'afrique du nord et
pressent déjà la guerre d'indépendance
puis ce sera l'un de chine où il
rencontre un caméraman des armées pierre
schoendoerffer
il ya donc un témoin un journaliste mais
à un moment donné à a dépassé le stade
de nos journalistes d'une certaine
manière pour avoir une autre vision pl -
patineuse mais une vision de fresques de
grands de grands romanciers il obtient
le prix interallié en 73 avec monsieur
le consul et huit ans plus tard le
goncourt avec anne-marie une histoire
d'amour haine avec sa mère colonisation
guerres révolutions décolonisation la
chine
l'indochine sont omniprésentes dans une
oeuvre souvent autobiographiques
c'est une partie de nous-mêmes qui
fichent le camp parce qu'il était
tellement comme un poisson dans l'eau
dans cette indochine qu'il adorait dans
cette atmosphère où se dégage quelque
chose des batteurs qu'on ne trouve pas
ailleurs
alors qu'audard dans tout ça il a fait
des bouquins formidable et sur la fin de
sa vie bodart cela sera tout de même du
baroud de la peur et de la misère
humaine
cette violence je l'aimais
professionnellement j'étais à témoins
j'ai dit à un genou qui s'est précipité
sur tous les charniers tous les cas
d'art et maintenant j'en ai assez et je
cherche avant tout la tranquillité la
paix le bonheur cinéma sorties cette
semaine deux boxeurs de jim sheridan
avec daniel day-lewis cette fois ci le
cinéaste irlandais nous propose une
nouvelle histoire sur fond de conflit en
irlande du nord entre catholiques et
protestants au brier de l'air à
patrimoine on reconnaît tout de suite
belfast unique dans son enchevêtrement
10,4 de béton et des barbelés dans ce
bout d'europe qui semble condamner un
hiver perpétuelle ressurgit danny flynn
ancien boxeur catholique militant bien
sûr de l'ira il vient de purger 14 ans
de prison pour un attentat qui n'a pas
commis mais dany a changé s'il a gardé
l'étoffé d'un champion
il rejette désormais n et terrorisme
je vais refaire une salle de gym pour
les enfants leur enseigner deux trois
trucs m'a appris à ne jamais lâcher
prise jack et c'est ce que je fais tu es
revenu pour te venger des dix noms c'est
finalement difficile de comprendre les
causes d'une guerre quand elle s'arrête
c'est une guerre ancien venu du passé
tout ce que je souhaite c'est que les
irlandais est enfin une vision de
l'avenir
osons une métaphore originale un boxeur
luttant contre la violence jim sheridan
nous montre une irlande du nord qui
risque de surprendre la cause de l'ira
est enracinée dans le passé et a créé
une société rétrograde et pétri de
conventions
le boxeur bravo si les tabous regagnant
l'amour de son ancien fiancé
aujourd'hui marié un militants
emprisonnés pourquoi tu m'as pas demandé
d'attendre je t'aurais attendu
tu peux pas dire ça 14 ans maggie et
aurait attendu jeunes avec saison
verrait pas confiance en moi
comment j'aurais eu confiance j'étais
fou amoureux les garder cet amour
attaque les irlandaises doivent se
sortir de leurs cartons et le plus être
fier d'une loyauté mal placé en d'autres
termes elle doit fuir la vie privilégié
le combat l'idéal plus que l'oeil
je pense que c'est une erreur hiding le
boxeur danny flynn malgré les
extrémismes de tous bords dit son espoir
en la réconciliation romantique effet si
miss deux boxeurs reste un film engagé
sur une blessure européennes qui sont
que l'on y prenne vraiment garde a fait
près de 3500 morts en 25 ans quel
endroit plus approprié que la gare
d'orsay à paris pour abriter
l'exposition manet monet sur la gare
saint lazare la rencontre de ces deux
géants de la peinture avec le
développement du chemin de fer georges
bigot
on l'appelait le cheval de fer et il
prenait qu'en coupe tous les rêves le
train intéresse les artistes depuis deux
siècles de cette puissance qui se dégage
de la locomotive à vapeur avec eux là la
vapeur et le métal puissant qui chauffe
si diabolique
ce contraste d'acier de vapeur c'est un
spectacle aussi beau qu'un foucher de se
hisser
c'est extraordinaire au 19e siècle le
train pour une grande part dans la
révolution industrielle mais il incarne
aussi l'évasion et pour les peintres la
possibilité de se rendre sur le motif de
peindre dans la nature des [ __ ] et
hautaine académique traité en atelier le
train et la gare passionne l'artiste
parce qu'ils apportent de neuf dans la
vie de ses contemporains sous napoléon
iii saint lazare est au coeur d'une
autre révolution l'aménagement de paris
par le baron haussmann et la place de
l'europe qui domine la gare attire les
peintres qu'il ait semble sans crier
gare de montmartre et des batignolles
pour s'installer dans ce nouveau
quartier caillebotte sur le premier zola
habite cet immeuble
lorsqu'il écrit la bête humaine tout à
côté au 4 de la rue saint pétersbourg
mal mais l'aîné des impressionnistes
transforme une salle d'armes en atelier
et reçoit ses cadets c'est là qu'il pas
une toile qui sera refusée au salon
officiel et qu'il intitule le chemin de
fer de locomotive points
mais la vapeur qui sort de ses naseaux
quant à monet il investit carrément la
gare saint lazare est accordé
l'autorisation de peindre dans la gare
et si on suit le tracé enfin les points
de vue qu'on peut repérer de par ses
tableaux on voit qu'il a vraiment été
dans toute la gare monnaies c'est quand
même c'est surtout un oeil et super
sensible et il 4-1 effets atmosphériques
est ordinairement rapidement il était
donc logique que le chef-d'oeuvre de
monnaie qui réalise 11 tableaux ici même
fut offert au public en une réplique
géante sur la façade de la gare saint
lazare pour annoncer l'exposition
d'orsay
avons-nous quitté le rappel du principal
titres de l'actualité de ce vin digne à
propos de violences scolaires un plan de
toute urgence pour l'un des départements
les plus touchés en france la seine
saint denis renfort en moyens en
personnels enseignants et assistants
voilà dans un instant la météo sophie
davant 20h50 mais ne soirée très foot
sur caen deux champions du monde un
divertissement présenté par patrice
laffont puis ensuite voilà marc d'un
monde à l'autre consacré ce soir aux
français et à leur passion je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur notre
chaîne bonsoir allemand
ce soit